1963 it started Russell brought it back
to Saturday night primetime all his
alienist there's something very
accessible in human abode where as but I
watched things like Star Trek heroic guy
for jocks they were they were they were
the people I could never aspire to be
whereas the doctor was sort of bundled
along you know he saved the world with
sticky back plastic in a couple of
microns I used to keep back plastic for
speed but of course you can use some
sticky tea
I love the bombing in money driving the
best view of all that simply does you're
not expected really to follow who went
before you're expected to bring yourself
to her
it's a great pride a thing to us that we
are handing it over line right now
trying to go okay we got we didn't mess
it up the way dr. Sharma is using a lot
of new technology it's not a limitless
budget we have gone movie budgets no so
actually I think we find ourselves being
as inventive and tricky with the way we
shoot exclusively if we take the bus
into a desert we still act with a real
bus into a desert because if you add up
the number of shots you can take a bus
to a desert than to do it all on green
screen we're going to shoot a scene
where a Lunt red London bus travels
through a wormhole in terms of space and
ends up on a desert planet so the very
quick practicality is you need to send a
bus to the desert which you need to do
for weeks and by Massabesic sweet
so we put a bus on a cargo container and
it chugs around the course tonight
finds its way to Dubai and then as the
bus has been taken off the cargo
carrying Freight it gets smashed to bits
with a cream
and there is no time to send another
besides us it's a very specific master
there aren't any duplicates of it as
we've already bought one Jewpacabra to
film it in britain so we need back to be
on it after after about an hour it took
1 minute to fix to just say we've got a
damaged bus in Dubai so that's what we
should we damaged if you drive a bus the
one horn time is basically gets a bit
battered couple of rewriters old
pictures because I grown up loving it
you kind of want to do it for your
eight-year-old self I suppose you want
your what your eight-year-old self to be
proud of what it is and to be captivated
and classified